hey
movie retrospective time yeah we got a
good one this time man [ __ ] bubba
hotep
oh man i love this movie i haven't
wanted to do this for so long and i was
like
you know i i subjected tom to like a
couple movies that he wasn't really
crazy about like the last two shows yeah
and like the last one i didn't do by
myself so i so this week i said okay
well toby's got this for free
so we're gonna do this one because we've
seen this movie lots of times and i know
you really like it
bubba hotep is a good example of
good writing writing that can just draw
you in
to characters and real good characters
in it man
it's got [ __ ] elvis jfks in it
yeah [ __ ]
the lone rangers in it that's right and
and a mummy an ancient egyptian mom is
it with cowboys
and they're all in the old folks home
and it's totally ludicrous total and of
course
jfk is black which yeah because why
wouldn't it be
of course he said the cia died him that
way they're hiding him yeah
yeah it's [ __ ] and he i just like
that character i was almost maybe
believing it as weird as the rest of the
movie
was maybe he was jfk sure why not and he
thought they were running him from a
battery
in the white house
because so much of the other [ __ ] is so
absurd about this movie
right that is real maybe that was
supposed to be
that's what i mean that's like not even
i like that they don't even like and
they don't even tell you if bruce
campbell's character is
actually elvis or if he's just like
delusional and thinks he's obvious i
think it's supposed to be
but it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
it is whatever you want
it to be yeah you can believe whatever
you want about any of these characters
i just roll with it that is elvis and
that is jfk
that's yeah that's kind of what i do
today and that was the lone ranger but i
think the guy who played the lone ranger
i don't think they lived at the same
time he would have been dead by
by that time yeah now i'm wondering i
can't even remember what that doctor's
name was it's
all a bunch of excuse me it's all a
bunch of old dudes in the convalescent
home losing their minds so
i just you know it's the dynamic of the
movie
is to not question their version of
reality right because for all we know
the mummy wasn't there but i think it
was
i think it was i think it was too yeah
but that's the thing okay so
now if you guys haven't seen bubba hotep
like i said it's on
uh 2b right now for free so you can go
watch it yeah this is a must-see
i used to have it on dvd but i was
temping at this
place like graphic designing there and i
loaned it to a guy that worked there and
then
i you know my temp job ended and he
didn't bring it back
if anybody want to give jenny a present
for for her birthday although like i
said it's um blu-ray
she'd love that i love this movie well
yeah everybody knows how much i love
bruce campbell so i'm gonna watch
anything with him in it even if it's bad
although i don't think i've ever seen a
bad movie that he's been in because he
just like
makes whatever he's in he's just he
seems like a delightful human being yeah
it's got an all-star cast and also
all stars behind the the uh the camera
too because
this is directed by the guy who did all
the phantasm don coscorelli yeah he's
awesome
and i love the phantasm movies to all of
them i think he did a great job in it oh
yeah
each one of them handcrafted works of
love you know with its own lore
its own mythos and everything and this
was
i think yeah it is and and before before
i get off the [ __ ]
the subject of phantasm phantasm
in my opinion is the only
movie series and there's five of them
all right where this
the series gets better as it goes
yeah it's really one that didn't fall
apart as it went on
it got better as it went i mean i guess
people could argue that because maybe
people don't like the later ones as much
but i
actually really liked all of them the
only thing that would be close would be
like
the back to the future trilogy some
people might say well back to future
three wasn't that good
now when you get older back to the
future three is very good it wasn't as
good when i was a teenager
but now that you know i'm an older guy i
appreciate
three a lot more than i used to i think
maybe the same could be said for bubba
hotep because
as ridiculous a premise as it is it's
actually
kind of it's deep yeah and it's actually
kind of like
touching yeah like in the way that it
talks about aging and it talks about how
we don't really value
like uh people old people like once
they're gone like everybody just like
wants to behind it
though was a deeper theme um is life
worth anything
yeah that's what it that's what it
that's really what it's about
i mean uh elvis his roommate was a dude
he didn't he was
he was there with him for three years he
didn't really know the guy that well
because he was never well enough to talk
when he died his daughter shows up
and his daughter never visited him and
threw his purple heart and his war
pictures away and elvis was like
hey could i have those i mean those
meant something to him yeah
and then you know he's like why didn't
you ever come see him and and in the end
[ __ ] elvis is asking himself what
is my what life worth anything yeah you
know
like because everything that you are
when you die
vanishes and everything you cared about
people other people don't give a [ __ ]
just throw it away
yeah and even like the guys who were
taking them to the [ __ ]
funeral home or the more putting them in
the hearse yeah yeah they're like
you ever wonder who these guys are man
whether or not they have a heritage
and like you know a legacy what their
legacy is the other guy's like
who gives a [ __ ] yeah there is a lot of
that in there yeah and when you get to
be my age you see people die
yeah these people in your own family die
and uh maybe
you know people that were married into
your own family or you know you've seen
young guys die
too but it's different you know a lot of
times when old people die
people are like ah good riddance you
know a lot of times
because you know they not everybody's
good you know but it makes you wonder
what what is life all about did that
guy's life mean anything
and then you gotta sit back and kind of
think you know like no it didn't really
mean much
you know had that guy never existed it
would have made a difference yeah it's
like what is the meaning of life
what is the meaning of a cat's life what
is the meaning of a bug's life
what is the meaning of a monkey's life
what is the meaning of a human's life
a lot of times it's all about that same
kind of nebulous
kind of thing well it doesn't really
mean anything it just happened
well and you have to make your own
meaning that's what
you know that's what i always and and i
like that better and
i think that's how this movie kind of
ended
with yeah they all went down fighting
for to save others and for what they
believed in
yeah and at the end the stars tell elvis
that all is well
yeah and he's like okay yeah because
it's all just part it's all just part of
the system
yeah don't worry about it which that's
my personal
which is very funny because like i said
this is kind of a deep movie for
for a movie about elvis and a black jfk
fighting a
an ass-sucking mummy yeah yeah he saw
him salted your ass
yeah he writes on bathroom walls
it's a great movie it's great it is so
okay so let's get a little bit into this
this came out in 2002
and like we said it was written and
directed by or actually adapted
and directed by uh don coskarelli who
was the most famous for the phantasm
movies
this is from a short story or novella by
joe r lansdale
uh who is a very very who is an awesome
horror writer from texas
uh if you haven't read any of his stuff
you really should because he is a
national treasure
um and a lot of his stories are real
weird like this and from what i remember
i do remember reading this story several
years ago
from what i remember this is a very
close adaptation of the story like i
remember it being very similar
so basically what you got elvis
or as he's called sebastian half
yeah what he says he's in a convalescent
home apparently he
um fell off a stage and broke a hip and
it got infected and he went into a coma
and then like he can't really walk
anymore so they put him in this
convalescent home
and he says that he's actually the real
elvis but that he switched places with
an elvis impersonator
sebastian named sebastian half to get
away from
the fame like they don't really like
when about
that was in the 70s sometime that yeah
it happened like while he was still
famous yeah and the guy who died in the
hotels on a toilet and [ __ ]
that wasn't elvis right that was about
that's what you know this impersonator
yeah
and they looked a lot alike there's a
great scene in this second movie
where elvis shows up to meet sebastian
half
kind of secretly he's got he's got the
memphis mob with
it he tells him they go to see evidently
he was on
like a mini tour to check to find like
the best
to check out the best [ __ ]
impersonators but he didn't he didn't
tell his boys
exactly why he wanted to do a switch
yeah
so he'd have them wait outside and he'd
go in and check them out you know and
he'd come
it and he'd come back out and go nah not
this one anyway
he goes in to go meet the the actual
sebastian half
and of course it's played by the same
actor yeah it's bruce campbell
and there's just this [ __ ] awesome
scene where the
impersonator stands up and sees [ __ ]
the real elvis
and [ __ ] he starts trembling and
falls to his knees and [ __ ]
and the king [ __ ] puts his hand out
and he [ __ ]
to offer his ring
so they make the switcheroo evidently
they make the switcheroo and then
sebastian half walks out to them to the
memphis mob and goes nah just another
loser
yeah and then it's okay they don't know
but they actually they made the switch
i do love that's how that's the story
we're told we don't know if it's true
yeah we don't know if like i mean he
seems to have his [ __ ] together
so i think it is elvis i think it is too
i think it's supposed to be but like i
said they don't really tell you that and
you don't really need to know
um it's basically here just operating
under the assumption that this is the
actual elvis and he switched places
one little thing too that i like about
that scene that's like kind of subtle
is that the impersonator before they
switch he's eaten a pie
because i guess he's thinner than the
real elvis so he's trying to fatten that
that's what i thought like they don't
really mention it but it's like
he's just in there like eating a pie
going up
[Laughter]
elvis walks up to him just kind of world
weary like yeah yeah he's going
there there you go okay
[ __ ] fights campbell is so [ __ ]
good these elvis is
all happening in one spot yeah two elvis
fanatics
the real elvis and a fanatic so as it
happens
so elvis and sebastian half they had
they had done like a contract right so
sebastian half
was supposed to like pretend he was
really elvis and he could have all the
money and the fame and he could do
everything like that
but they had a contract where the real
elvis would have enough money to live on
and then he would just go back
and live as an elvis impersonator
however and they had a deal too that
it's like if elvis ever wanted to come
back to his real life he could like they
had a caveat
but what ended up happening was that
elvis
was having a barbecue at his trailer he
said his trailer and he set his trailer
on fire with probably
like actually it was a huge explosion
and he lost the contract
so he couldn't go back no that's right
these whole elvis scenes are not really
the main
part of the movie these are all
flashbacks he's trying to explain how he
got
to the audience the audience he's
explaining to the audience basically
how he got to where their weather and he
really is evidently the real elvis
that's yeah that's the purpose of that
um the main the main thing about the
story is that
the people inside the old folks home are
getting attacked by a [ __ ]
soul-sucking
mommy mommy and happens jfk happens to
be in this same
little rinky dink in mud creek texas med
mud creek texas old dilapidated house
and he happens to be in there and it's
[ __ ] funny that
he they all call him mr president and
[ __ ] and like when you go into his room
his room looks like the presidential
office except there's like framed
pictures of like lee harvey
he makes elvis swear to him he had
nothing to do with that night
it's [ __ ] it's awesome it's awesome i
gotta say aussie davis
this i this might have been his last
movie because i think he died like not
too long after this
um but he had like a very very long um
you know successful career in acting
and uh i'm sure he must like he's a very
serious actor so it must have been like
funny to be approached to play a movie
like this
but he [ __ ] knocks it out of the park
the fact that he is so
straight yeah and believes it he doesn't
come off
like a crazy person he comes off like
he's actually jfk
and he's you know he has the gravitas
and everything so you don't laugh at him
nice he's doing a [ __ ] real jfk yeah
and it's excellent it's
excellent it's just so [ __ ] funny
like the lines in this are just so
[ __ ] funny because
like though like um so elvis doesn't
really know anybody else
calls him jack and he yeah hey jack
hey jack so uh tell me tell me about
maryland
monroe how was she in the sack
that is classified information
she was funny as [ __ ] i need all
classified information yeah that's how
he says it it's like all this [ __ ] like
um because you know elvis is talking to
is talking to jfk and he's just like
you know it's you know i i don't want to
like offend you or anything like that
he's like you know jfk was a white man
yeah and then jfk goes you think i don't
know that
they dyed me this color he goes
the cia did the cia was hiding him yeah
and then
his family would come to visit him and
he goes
the woman who who claims that she's my
niece yeah
to visit me [ __ ] funny and he says
that
he did get um shot at in dallas
but that the cia put his brain back
together and they packed it with sand
packed with bags of sand but that his
actual brain
is like connected to a battery at some
white house
or something like that it's connected to
some kind of broadcasting device that's
battery powered it's back at the white
house he's worried that they might
that that battery might die or they
might shut that off so he's slightly
remote control or claims to be
but he was saying that the cia had
brilliant
technology you know and when and when
the mummy first shows up
he at first thinks it's lyndon johnson
yeah like coming to finish him yeah
jesus lyndon johnson
but like i said the fact that we can't
spoil all the [ __ ] the thing that i
love about this movie
is that as within the tone of the movie
it's plausible though
that's what i mean well they took like
really the most ridiculous premise you
could come up with like on earth
but they made it's kind of low-key like
it's not
zany it's not like over-the-top it's not
everything is kind of played straight
like
the humor is very understated kind of
um and it's also like i said it's kind
of like a touching
yeah deep like exploration of aging and
like friendship and like one last stand
like being a hero like saving other
people and like giving your life meaning
and stuff
so it's just like i really love that
juxtaposition
yeah you see it but the flashbacks will
take you to other locations and the way
it's filmed it's it's really cool it
kind of reminds me of the phantasm
yeah the cinematography yeah
photography's good one and then
when they're inside and around the uh
the convalescent home
it's got a good tone it's kind of a
crappy convalescent home
and they have to find out where this
[ __ ] mummy's coming from
and everything is done within the scope
of what an old man can do like you know
they got
walkers and in [ __ ] wheelchairs
trying to fight a damn
mummy yeah and i don't want to steal the
movie it's just
and it does make sense
within the context of the lore of the
movie um i mean
jfk over the years in this movie
has become uh an expert on the
paranormal
and um uh uh
magic i guess yeah you know [ __ ]
witchcraft he's got all kind of books
about [ __ ] like that
he has to go check out his books yeah so
he can explain most of this
because it's because he's researched it
yeah
conveniently which like i said it's like
it's ridiculous but it's not you totally
buy into it because it's not winking in
itself it's not
like that right you know what i mean
they're just taking it completely
serious because elvis is a paranormal
skeptic
yeah i can't understand it's how could
mommy come back to life
i don't get it why is it here we're
what would in texas mummy be doing in
texas yeah but then they don't know
they do actually find out like how it
got there yeah
but yeah so and and the funny thing too
is that like i said the premise is
ridiculous
but it's also there's like a lot of you
know real low brow kind of humor like i
said you know the mummy like
basically sucks your soul out your
[ __ ] yeah um
and you know he's got a cancerous dick
he's got yeah he's got a growth on his
dick
he talks about it and they have to let
he does talk about it a lot he worries
about he doesn't talk about it
internal monologue he's worrying about
what's happened what's growing on his
dick
and he's impotent and like yeah and so
like you do get scenes where like the
nurse has to come in and like put the
corticosteroid like stuff on i can't
remember what her name is that actress
because she's in like a bunch of
yeah a nurse is kind of like this uh
kind of bombshell kind of
black chick she's probably about 50.
yeah probably and
uh she's got to go in there and [ __ ]
treat his dick and [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's embarrassing to the king well yeah
as it would be
yeah and she's teasing him all the time
about it
it's a great movie it's a great movie it
is like i said it seems like
what ended up happening with it it came
out
and they really only had i heard they
only had like
32 prints of it yeah and so
they basically did well like wikipedia
says they just road showed it
and that they just took these one they
just kind of like took them around the
country to different theaters
to show them and um it ended up getting
a really good
um you know really good buzz because
it's you know it's a cult classic and i
mean who doesn't love
the writing is grace campbell who
doesn't love [ __ ] the phantasm movies
don coskarelli you know who doesn't love
joerlandsale who's read him
so it's like it was really kind of the
you know the perfect storm but
the fact that it was hard to see it
because there were only 32 copies of it
and if you didn't live in a city that
they went to
to show it then you didn't get to see it
till later on so when it came out on dvd
it already had like this huge built-in
audience that wanted to get it because
they had been wanting to see it and
hearing about it and everything like
that
because like i said how can you not want
to see a movie called
bubba hotep that's about a [ __ ]
and i love that the mummy is just
wearing cowboy boots in a cowboy house
for no reason there's nothing
in texas i guess he bought them like on
those
i think he found him i think he might
have found it he found him because he
he got lost in texas it's kind of
explained
yeah i don't how long ago i can't i'm
not real clear on how long ago
it was the 60s wasn't it yeah it seemed
like it had been a long time so the
mummy's been preying on the old people
at this place for a long time
i guess it was wearing their clothes but
oh yeah maybe that's what it was i
didn't think about that yeah stealing
clothes from the local people yeah
clothes on i got it and uh it's just a
good movie man
uh as good as a phantasm movie as good
as a
as a evil dead movie i would i think the
tone is closer to a phantasm movie of
course
same director yeah uh the writing is
really good
it's more a comedy than horror um comedy
mystery comedy paranormal
mystery sleuth movie with action old man
action old man action yeah yeah we got
and kimo sabe is in there too yeah
[ __ ] yeah
we went down fighting soul intact
yeah yeah it's just like it's just so
it's so
sweet like the the friendship between
elvis and jfk
and like them just like solving the
mystery and how they're gonna kill this
mummy and
well it makes sense because you got
elvis he's basically the star and the
narrator of this movie
all right so of course it's at the end
of his life but it's still
elvis's in innate internal instincts
to make [ __ ] having to do with himself
as cool as [ __ ] possible
yeah so you're in your 80s trying to
make what you're doing
sound as cool as [ __ ] possible when
not much
all physically happen well it kind of
does
yeah but you know but like you said you
have you got a walker and [ __ ]
yeah i mean in the context of these are
two very old men who can barely walk
yeah and you know they have to fight a
mummy yeah and they're not really
entirely sure what they're doing
they got all kinds of uh you know
medicine bags and [ __ ] special
[ __ ] talismans and
flamethrowers homemade flames words of
power words of power
stuff that they dreamt up in [ __ ] or
something they read in books jfk read
about it in a book
you just got to see it it's a must-see
it's a must-see it really it's it's like
the quintessential
it's one of the quintessential like cult
movies yeah you know what i mean
and like i said the [ __ ]
cinematography is beautiful the score
is fantastic it's exactly yeah that's
right the score what like a
sun bleached texas movie would sound
like
like it's really good also i have to say
but the action scenes all have [ __ ]
black metal playing
do you know yeah yeah heavy metal or
black metal [ __ ]
yeah and all the stuff with the scarab
beetles and everything like that super
funny
and it's like like i said this is early
2000s 2002 so it's all as far as i know
it's all
practical effects they don't do anything
or anything um yeah so the bugs are all
uh yeah he fights a scared beetle about
the size of a damn
apple yeah bigger actually size of a
crab
at least and the mummy makeup looks
really good like bubba hoop
looks really good yeah there's like some
parts where bubba hotep
he the bubba hotep was not his name
that's what elvis that's what elvis
calls
like some kind of bubba hotep
but bubba hotep looked at him in their
mind
their minds touched yeah they had like
visions from from from boba hoda
like what happened what happened to him
like how he died yeah elvis has all
kinds of spiritual movements and [ __ ]
in there
which is great man [ __ ] that like i
said the writing is absolutely brilliant
i just i just love this movie it's one
of those movies that it's like any time
i want to be like oh
you know what i mean like i just watch
it it's just like elvis talks about
cilla
talks about his daughter what kind of
[ __ ] had it been different you know he
had a lot of regrets
a little lot of regrets and he's like
like i said a lot of it it's just about
aging and like what happens when you get
old and ever you know everyone in your
life is like falling away and nobody's
gonna give a [ __ ] about you after you
die
and yeah and these are all famous dudes
and nobody comes to see them hardly
anymore they're all kind of forgotten so
they all got to take care of each other
yeah it's like it's really cool it's
like i really really like the way they
they kind of played with that theme and
like i said it's like really sweet and
like really
heartfelt yeah and i think that's what
makes it work they didn't do it like a
jokey
like it's a funny like a bizarre premise
but they didn't do it like real jokey
they did it like
yeah there's also a lot of like
spiritual truths universal truths in it
yeah that's
like i said it we said it earlier on in
the review there that's actually
a deceptively deep movie it is it's easy
and like i said it's kind of sad but
not in a not in a boohoo kind of way but
like an appointment it has a happy
ending
yeah yeah i mean yeah i guess you could
say that
the circle was complete soul intact
because remember they were talking about
reincarnation and afterlife
yeah yeah yeah if bubba hotep got a hold
of you there wouldn't be any of that
yeah you would just you would just cease
to exist and he would [ __ ] you out in
the toilet yeah
you would just go through bubbles yes
soul residue
yeah you'd [ __ ] out some soul resident
yeah that's [ __ ] funny
like i said it sounds like it sounds
ridiculous like it almost sounds like a
truman movie like when you're talking
about it like with all the poop and
everything but it's like it's just not
it's just that's what i like about it is
this just juxtaposition
of like the weirdness that was how jfk
described it yeah
they would just crap you out like soul
residue
but like the fact that ozzy davis is so
[ __ ] good at this
it's like he's just completely straight
faced completely like i said you just
[ __ ] buy it and it's just so
[ __ ] funny and elvis is going oh my
god
i don't know man i don't know
so good it's so good it's just like yeah
so um
i wanted to say too while we were
talking about phantasm uh oh reggie
bannister
has kind of a cameo in this i think he's
like the head of the
he's yeah he's in charge of the nursing
home i think he's only like in a couple
of scenes
yeah but it was like it's always nice to
see him because we love reggie you know
what i mean
but yeah so i mean if you haven't seen
bubba hotep
and you're looking five thumbs up and
your five thumbs up
thumbs big toes legendary
it is yeah like i said it's not it's not
going to be like an over the top if
you're expecting like a crazy over the
top kind of maybe it's not really like
that
movie's got soul but yeah it's just it's
just a really weird
it's hard to describe to somebody you
can vibe with the movie yeah you just go
okay yeah
yeah yeah it is it's like a really cool
i mean we just kind of like laid down
the bed i was like
i was like i just love this movie it's
like i said i love bruce campbell and
i've read all his books and it's a very
wise and good natured movie
it is yeah good nature that's a good way
of putting it it's just like a really
really sweet
movie and it's like i really really like
it a lot like i said i used to have it
on dvd somebody
took it they didn't mean to steal it
they just didn't get it back to me in
time
but um yeah it's actually if you want to
watch it it's on 2b for free
right now the weird thing about it
though is we were watching it last night
and you know 2b has ads like every now
and then like commercials
and it went to an ad like as like the
second the movie ended
and then it didn't show any credits no
like it just went to the next movie
which was saturday the 14th
which i haven't seen in a million
[ __ ] years i need to watch that [ __ ]
again
at some point that was yeah it was like
a slasher parody i guess it came out in
80
early 80s i don't remember um i saw it a
bunch of times on cable
but yeah so i don't remember because i
think what they did was that
they made like at the end of the credits
if i remember correctly
they had like a joke like like they were
jokingly saying they were gonna make a
sequel
that was called like something like but
what the [ __ ] was it called bubba
nosferatu
yeah like the she vampires or something
like that
and it wasn't they weren't really gonna
make it it was just like a joke
but then the movie did so well like on
you know
as a cult classic that they started
talking about maybe we should make a
sequel or a prequel or something like
that
what they ended up doing they did
actually uh work on it for a while
um in the in like 2008 2009 but then i
think it went into development hell
and then i think what ended up happening
was that joe r lansdale
actually wrote a graphic novel that is
like a five
volume one that's like a prequel you
know but they wanna like expand it like
have elvis like fight aliens with
colonel parker and all those other kind
of things
yeah but they i don't know if that's i
don't think that happens in the one they
have but that was like another idea that
they were floating
that they were doing you know a prequel
to like funny elvis in this movie says
he should have fired colonel parker
yeah yeah well
but yeah so definitely definitely go to
tubia and check this out it's like just
a really
i i just love this movie so much it just
like warms the cockles of my heart every
time i watch it and i've seen it like a
million times
but uh yeah definitely definitely
recommended on 2b
go check it out do it and we'll see you
later